que je vais vous parler d'un sujet qui
n'est pas forcément le plus simple je
vous parlais de l'avenir de notre
planète certes mais surtout de l'avenir
du vivant de cette planète
ce qu'on appelle la biodiversité alors
je m'appelle jérémy allain je suis
directeur d'une association de
protection de la nature et mon
engagement
il est il remonte à très loin de mon
engagement en fait il a commencé très
jeune en premier projet de protection de
la nature j'avais 11 ans est tout
simplement parce que un jour en
regardant peut-être okapi peut-être la
télévision je ne m'en souviens plus je
vois que les rhinocéros allait
disparaître
pour moi la disparition de la nature
c'était pas possible pour moi les
rhinocéros faisait partie de notre
patrimoine pour moi quelque chose qui
disparaissait c'était les dinosaures pas
les rhinocéros
alors bien évidemment avec mon collège
voilà je pars dans l'idée de
sensibiliser les gens à la protection de
la nature et la biodiversité et sous cet
axe du rhinocéros et puis très vite je
vois que cette passion montrent que je
m'intéresse aux oiseaux et parents me
vois sortir la nuit courir après les
grenouilles je vais compter les
papillons
j'aime en fait tout simplement se vivent
cette biodiversité qui nous entoure et
puis bien évidemment à l'adolescence
alors pour faire un parallèle la bière
mais à cette adolescence
on me dit mais ça sert à quoi ton
travail à quoi ça va servir de
s'intéresser à la nature
je m'étais pas posé la question pour moi
protéger la nature
c'était simplement protéger les vivants
et comme on le disait à cette époque on
devait simplement léguer aux générations
futures une planète saine et puis c'est
vrai que cette question m'a taraudé
régulièrement
non mais pourquoi à quoi ça sert en fait
de préserver la nature
à quoi ça sert de préserver la
biodiversité et heureusement les nations
unies s'est annoncée
et bah c'est pas grave heureusement les
nations-unies en fait dès le début des
années 2000 sont aussi posé la question
et sont posés la question soit demandant
donc ça sert à quoi le b diversité alors
plane scientifiques sont réunis pendant
des années et puis ils ont fait le même
constat
ce constat c'était que la nature nous
rendait des services une multitude de
services
alors ils ont catalogués en beauté
service est bien évidemment un des
premiers services c'est celui qu'on
appelle le service d'approvisionnement
quand vous mangez du poisson c'est la
biodiversité quand vous chauffer au bois
c'est la biodiversité
quand vous construisez une maison en
bois c'est de la biodiversité et puis la
biodiversité aussi c'est une source de
médicaments est aussi une source
d'avenir
vous avez la photo ici la davière qu'on
appelle l'art et nicole et qui
certainement demain nous rendre à de
nombreux services notamment dans le
cadre des transfusions sanguines dans le
cadre des transplantations d'organes 12e
service c'est celui qu'on appelle le
service de régulation
on connaît toute cette histoire de
coccinelles qui va manger nos puits
seront mais c'est aussi ses arbres ses
arbres qui vont stocker une partie notre
co2 et dans un contexte de réchauffement
climatique où on sait également que le
réchauffement climatique aura
certainement un incident sur la
biodiversité
on a fortement besoin et puis bien
évidemment un service très connue c'est
le service de pollinisation
on a besoin d'insectes pour pouvoir
polliniser à sa tombe à sa banque de
plantes mais j'y reviendrais tout à
l'heure alors dernier service définies à
l'échelle internationale
c'est le service culturel c'est le
simple fait de profiter de la nature de
pouvoir avoir des paysages de pouvoir se
balader dans la nature
et puis si on commence à s'intéresser un
peu à une science c'est pas l'économie
de l'environnement parce que les
économies sont très vite arrivés à
s'intéresser aussi à l'aide de la
diversité à combien ça rapporte et tous
à la nature et bien si on prend
simplement l'exemple de la bretagne
on sait par exemple que 69 % des
touristes qui viennent en bretagne c'est
pas pour la température de notre eau
dommage c'est pour la qualité de nos
paysages la singularité de nos paysages
et donc on a plutôt intérêt à
s'intéresser de près à nos paysages à
les préserver tout simplement pour
garder certains éléments l'économie
alors moi ça me suffisait pas mal tout
ça c'était bien voilà et puis mes amis
mes amis très proches qui certains sont
conviés d'autres chauffeurs poids lourds
à quoi ça sert la nature et oreca eureka
au restaurant ya pa très très bon tu en
étais à mon épouse en train de manger au
restaurant et puis un autre assiette on
avait voilà on avait un petit plat de
poisson mort a dit williams
et puis un moment je me suis posé la
question suivante mais mon ami plombier
eleven ans resteront travailler mais si
je partais de mon plat peut-être que je
pourrai aussi définir les emplois liés à
cette biodiversité
bien évidemment le pêcheur le cuisinier
le marché mais bien évidemment également
plein d'autres le marièrent le serveur
le grossiste et ainsi de suite
on a trouvé plus d'une trentaine facile
mais une trentaine d'emplois s'en va là
sans trop chercher et le comptable qui
travaille pour un pêcheur mais
évidemment qu'il fait la comptabilité
mitraille également grâce à la
biodiversité
et puis en regardant ce plat et en
connaissant assez bien les processus
biologiques me suis aussi aperçu que mon
poisson notamment certaines des espèces
de poissons ont besoin dans leur cycle
biologique de milieux sensibles et
précis qui sont les herbus littoraux
essence et airbus il ya tout simplement
pas de poisson que bien évidemment
morilles ou les légumes poussent sous un
seul sur un seul dans le fonctionnement
écologique et biologique est
prépondérant dans l'importance notamment
économique de ces ressources
alimentaires et puis bien évidemment
quand on aime l'art à tatouille on sait
de quoi elle est faite et sans insectes
pollinisateurs
sans abeilles sambre bon pas de tomates
pas de congé alors à partir de tout ça
et quand je discute avec mes amis je
redis voilà la nature et nous aurons les
services et les basses et kool shen
laurent des services n'a pas dans le
pays alors c'est vrai vous avez besoin
d'un impayé
par contre ce qui est peut-être grave
est ce qui est certainement grave c'est
l'état de santé de cette biodiversité
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de
cette sixième extinction la dernière
c'était une au fameux dinosaures
on part de la sixième extension du
vivant sur la planète
on pourrait presque on pourrait le vivre
c'est presque incroyable impensable et à
partir de ces éléments là je me suis dit
mais comment présenter l'érosion de la
biodiversité est ce que vous avez fait
attention est ce que vous avez remarqué
que cette biodiversité disparaît c'est
alors le truc qui est assez connue c'est
l'histoire du pare brise plus besoin
maintenant l'été de nettoyer le pare
brise régulièrement parce que plus
d'insectes et qui dit + 1 sec 10 plus
d'oiseaux moi j'aime cette définition la
définition de robert barbault de la
biodiversité qui dit la biodiversité
c'est le tissu du vivant les suivis
scientifiques qui permettent notamment
de voir l'évolution de la biodiversité
sur la planète ont commencé presque
quand je suis né dans les années 70 et à
l'époque le tissu du vivant et bien
c'était c'était ça c'était quelque chose
ou la biodiversité étaient présents de
la biodiversité était lié la
biodiversité fonctionnait bien et puis
depuis 40 ans qu'est ce que l'on a fait
premièrement c'est pas très intéressée à
la diversité
et puis les zones humides bas on a
construit dessus on sait pas trop poser
question et puis les petits d'un seuil
des petits oiseaux
blop ça ça pas grand chose on s'en fout
bon le rhinocéros s'est pas non plus
super grave
un récit naos et rose de plus ou de
moins ça n'a pas changé la face du monde
et puis mon lotissement
je peux le faire ici il ya peut-être de
la biodiversité mais bon ça préoccupe
qui
et puis petit à petit et année après
année mais on s'aperçoit cette
biodiversité et disparaissent et dans
les années soixante dix quand moi
j'avais la chance d'avoir une couverture
et un tissu du vivant chouette
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons perdu 60% du
vivant de cette planète 60% alors deux
solutions soit en pleurs
ça va pas faire jeu ça va pas changer la
face du monde soit on réagit alors entre
nous moi je préfère bien évidemment la
réaction
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
connaît les mécanismes on sait pourquoi
la biodiversité disparaît donc si on
sait pourquoi elle disparaît et les
mécanismes sont les mène à l'autre bout
du monde que en bretagne si on sait
qu'elle disparaît on peut trouver aussi
des solutions
la première cause de disparition la
biodiversité au monde
c'est ce qu'on appelle la destruction
des habitats naturels vous imaginez
aisément que lorsqu'on détruit une mare
où se reproduisent les amphibiens et ben
on va détruire en fait un habitat qui
était favorable à cette biodiversité
cette photo elle été prises notamment
dans une zone dunaire où on a détruit
cette dune tout simplement pour y faire
une décharge
mais quelques années plus tard
l'intelligence humaine a été capable de
faire ça aussi est de recréer des
milieux naturels préservés ces milieux
et créer à s'étendre là une réserve
naturelle réserve naturelle étant un
outil pour des sont de nature très
performant l'autre cause de disparition
de la biodiversité c'est l'introduction
d'espèces invasives ou souvent des
espèces exotiques exotiques qui vont
arriver en fait dans un milieu qui n'est
pas le leur c'est le cas par exemple de
la renault du japon on en verra d'autres
c'est le cas de la petite tortue qu'on a
tous acheté quand on était petit petite
tortue de floride on va balancer dans la
mare du coin parce que c'est pas
forcément très très sympa ce geste a
entraîné en grande partie de la
disparition de la tortue française et on
sait si ces prix on attend on sait
comment réagir
on sait qu'on peut agir efficacement
bien évidemment on était très très fort
aussi en chimie mais aujourd'hui et
c'est une autre cause de disparition de
la biodiversité
on sait également que l'on peut faire
sens on peut cultiver
on peut faire un jardin sans traitement
autre cause également la disparition de
la biodiversité
c'est ce qu'on appelait la
surexploitation des ressources
le cas le plus connu c'est notamment le
clat le cas ici de la morue notamment
qui a été surpêché est tellement péché
qu'on est arrivé à un moment où les
stocks ne pourrait pas se refaire et où
aujourd'hui
eh bien elle est plus plus pêchable mais
cet exemple pour la morue l'est aussi
pour plein d'autres par contre on a ici
en baie de saint-brieuc un exemple
intéressant csu de la coquille saint
jacques
l'oci a failli disparaître elle a si
elle aussi à feu y ait de surexploiter
mais les pêcheurs ont trouvé des
systèmes tout simplement pour faire en
sorte que cette biodiversité essai de
ressources soient exploitées durablement
alors c'est pas toujours simple c'est
pas toujours évident de savoir quoi
faire
qu'est ce que moi je peux faire en tant
que citoyen à mon niveau
s'il ya quelque chose qu'il faut retenir
c'est que les enjeux de biodiversité
ça se joue sur le terrain ça se joue
certainement aussi à paris vous vous
demandez à paris sur le terrain mais je
veux dire dans dans des grands
séminaires dans dans le fait de rédiger
des actes ou prendre des conventions
internationales et compagnie mais ça se
passe surtout essentiellement sur le
terrain alors bien évidemment moi
citoyen je peux agir je peux agir aussi
bien évidemment dans mes choix de
consommation
le fait de consommer notamment l'huile
de palme bah c'est une incidence directe
sur la biodiversité alors bien
évidemment pas la biodiversité à côté de
chez vous mais ça l'est le bout du monde
chacun peut s'impliquer s'investir
auprès de gestionnaires d'espacés
naturels auprès de l'association auprès
de collectivités qui se met en place des
actions de la diversité et vous en avez
quelques exemples le fait de participer
à des actions de nettoyage de plage
permet en fait de réduire l'impact sur
la biodiversité pouvez aussi participer
à des études scientifiques et certains
même si nous avons c'est le cas de
bénévoles à nous tous les matins pendant
qu'elle mois font traverser la route aux
amphibiens notamment parce qu'il ya une
zone où ils peuvent se faire écraser
amène évidemment que ce n'est pas
durable dans le temps mais avec ses
études un ou deux ans voire trois ça
nous permettra demain de propositions de
proposer des solutions concrètes à ce
que cette biodiversité elles puissent
continuer à se développer notamment son
secteur
alors vous avez aussi et j'espère pour
vous partez de certains un jardin et on
peut aussi agir directement dans son
jardin
l'ensemble des jardins des français
représentent environ la surface cinq
fois plus en fait
la surface des réserves naturelles de
france soit plus d'un million d'hectares
donc mis bout-à-bout vous pouvez aussi
faire de votre jardin des offres de paix
de la biodiversité en créant des marrons
n'ayant gestion différenciée en ans en
installant des plantes favorable à ces
biodiversité
vous aussi bien évidemment et sans
soucis accueillir les hirondelles sur
votre sur votre mur elles ont vraiment
besoin
la biodiversité c'est aussi bien
évidemment la responsabilité des
collectivités
vous pouvez être tous des ambassadeurs
de la biodiversité auprès de vos amis
la collectivité elle peut bien
évidemment mettre en place des actions
sur ces espaces verts
c'est simple les actions qu'il faut
qu'il faut faire valider souvent parce
que voilà je trouve parfois que l'on met
en place plutôt des élections qui sont
plutôt du greenwashing que des
transactions de sensibiliser peu de
dépréciations de gestion de la
biodiversité
parce que si vous laissez notamment la
flore s'exprimer c'est très bien si vous
y passez un coup dur au voyage vous
comprendrez très vite que vous allez
bien évidemment broyer la végétation
mais aussi toute la biodiversité qui est
associé donc c'est pas simple mais les
solutions existent et puis les
collectivités peuvent aussi agir
efficacy efficacement contre les espèces
invasives
alors ça l'exemple est très bon l'herbe
de la pompe à l'herbe de la pampa on
peut lutter contre cette herbe mais
contre plein d'autres espèces invasives
également et un rapport que j'ai
beaucoup aimée qui est celui ci c'est
aussi une cause de disparition de la
biodiversité
le titre c'est les aides publiques
dommageables à la biodiversité est
évidemment que lorsque l'on prévoit des
aménagements sans prendre en compte les
enjeux de biodiversité et ben les aides
qui ont financé les routes par exemple
ont un impact sur cette belle diversité
on peut faire aussi d'éducation
d'environnement c'est important avec un
bémol un bémol simple
souvent ils trop souvent j'ai entendu
dire oui on va mettre en place des
actions de sensibilisation des enfants
comme ça demain e règleront les
problèmes de biodiversité
non les problèmes de biodiversité c'est
aujourd'hui c'est maintenant de quel
droit nous devrons laisser à nos enfants
en fait cet héritage aucun droit et puis
c'est aussi de l'engagement des les
collectivités vers des programmes plus
plus engageant notamment de plus en plus
vont développer ce qu'on appelle les
programmes de territoires engagés pour
la biodiversité
damman qui émane également du grenelle
de l'environnement qui démontrait que
finalement à l'échelle d'une
intercommunalité d'une commune on
connaissait pas forcément bien la faune
la flore et tout ce patrimoine naturel
qui étaient présents sur notre
territoire
or il faut que les collectivités
s'engagent et qu'elle s'engage à
recenser cette biodiversité recensés
cette biodiversité ça permet également
d'aménager en prenant en compte le
patrimoine naturel et puis ça permet
également de mettre en place des actions
précises cohérente pour accueillir la
biodiversité pour permettre à ces
espèces de se déplacer parce que comment
on le voyait tout à l'heure avec le
cadre des amphibiens les amphibiens par
exemple se reproduise en ai marre mais
vivre le reste de l'année à un kilomètre
de ces points d'eau mais évidemment si
une route est artisanale il ya aucun
déménagement qui est prévu pour eux ben
on aime la diversité et dans ces cas là
menacer du mois les les
les fonctionnalités écologiques alors
oui mais souvent on dit oui mais
monsieur alain combien ça coûte combien
ça coûte de sauver de la nature c'est
une vraie question
une intercommunalité une agglomération
qui voudraient se lancer dans des
programmes ambitieux de reconquête de la
biodiversité
ben c'est quoi ça rond point c'est
l'équivalent d'un rond point voire un
demi ronds points pour agir concrètement
pour la biodiversité pour agir
concrètement pour les générations
futures
à l'échelle de la france et un dixième
de porte avions on peut demain si on
veut agir sur la biodiversité facilement
travailler sur des actions concrètes sur
le terrain il faut juste il faut juste
un peu de moyens et peu de moyens et un
peu de moyens c'est quelques ronds
points au final
alors vous je sais pas moi ce que je
sais c'est que nous avons des devoirs
ce que je sais c'est que cette
biodiversité nous rend plein de services
cette biodiversité elle donne à manger
cette biodiversité et nous permet de
respirer cette biodiversité et de donner
du plaisir ce que j'ai également c'est
que cette biodiversité est en train de
disparaître que l'on peut mettre en
place des actions alors vous je sais pas
mais moi pour mes enfants pour l'avenir
de la planète
je pense que nous devons essayer ce qui
n'a jamais été tenté
merci
[Applaudissements]